children who were separated from their
parents
under the trump administration are the
subject of an intense
effort in an all-of-government effort
directed by president biden
to find the parents and reunite
the families and restore our nation
uh to its core principles and values
we appointed a incredibly talented and
dedicated executive director
michelle brennan to lead the task force
i am the chair along with the
secretaries
of state health and human services and
the attorney general of the united
states this is a full-time effort
by talented and dedicated individuals
not only in the department of homeland
security but in the other departments
that i mentioned we look forward to
working with this committee
with other members of congress and
harnessing the talent and
resources of the private sector and
community-based organizations
in this effort we have an obligation
to find the parents and to reunite
those families
thank you very much uh earlier this
month
uh while visiting a fema
fascination center in philadelphia
you express the view that a person's
socioeconomic status race
ethnicity access to transportation
or immigration status should not
impact their ability to receive a
vaccine
i cannot agree with you anymore
can you share with the committee uh how
you are
making that a reality
mr chairman the issue of equity
is a core foundation
of the all of government effort to
address and tackle the challenge of the
covet 19
endemic fema uses a
social vulnerability index that
addresses the vulnerabilities that you
identify
in ensuring that the placement of the
community vaccinate vaccination centers
address the issue of equity and equality
of access to the vaccines
i will share with you that i participate
along with other cabinet members
in a weekly meeting led by jeffrey zeins
who leads the all of government effort
on behalf of president biden
and the issue of equity
and the emphasis on equity begins our
discussions
every week it is uppermost in our minds
and that too is a core obligation of
ours
thank you very much i now recognize the
ranking member
of the full committee the gentleman from
new york mr catco
for students thank you mr chairman and
thank you mr secretary for
the way you've been accessible and uh
they've reached out to me several times
i've had several good discussions
already
and i appreciate us getting off on the
right foot and i want to commend all the
men and women at the department of
homeland security and all the subsidiary
agencies
for the great work they do every day uh
i encountered many of those this week
uh this weekend in el paso where i
started my career as a prosecutor
and where i did went after cartels and i
know from then and i know now that
they're
they're the frontline people they're the
front line workers and what the
the the discussions you have with them
really ring through
and after discussing things with them i
became that much more alarmed about
what's going on at the border
and as we discussed yesterday in a phone
call i've got a series of questions that
really require just a yes or no answer
and i was appreciative you just go
through those quickly um
if you could confirm some of these for
me uh first of all do you agree that
president biden signed multiple
executive actions on his first day in
office
uh to uh one halt border wall
construction
two and the remaining mexico policy and
three
cancel asylum agreements with central
american partners
i do and if i may um uh mr ranking
member
i appreciated our two conversations thus
far
and the spirit of partnership to which
we are both uh committed
uh i share your background as a federal
prosecutor and i know we will accomplish
a great deal
together may i just say one quick thing
about the administration yes you can be
very brief because i have several
questions
i will because i i i share uh
your tremendous pride in the men and
women of the border patrol and the men
and women across the department of
homeland security
when i took office on february 2nd two
percent
of the board of frontline border patrol
personnel had been vaccinated and what i
heard
first and foremost was the fact that
their health and well-being had not been
taken care of we
launched operation val vaccinate our
workforce
and over 26 percent of the front line
personnel
are now vaccinated and thank you mr
secretary i don't mean to cut you off
but i do have many questions i do
appreciate
you taking care of the agents that's
very commendable also do you agree that
customers of border patrol encountered
uh protection encountered more than 100
000 individuals in february
which was 173 increase from february
2020
just yes or no um uh the numbers with
respect to february of this year
are accurate uh mr ranking member thank
you and uh
2020. can you confirm that customers and
border protections donna facility was
recently at
over 700 capacity i don't have the
precise figure it was certainly over
capacity
mr ranking member and we are addressing
that thank you can you confirm that
homeland security has asked for
volunteers to help manage
the quote overwhelming end quote number
of migrants at the border
i'm sorry can you repeat the question mr
banking member sure thank you
can you confirm that homeland security
has asked for volunteers to help manage
the
overwhelming end quote number of
migrants at the border uh we have uh
certainly called upon the volunteer
workforce
to assist in managing uh the border as
we have done
uh before and we have done in many
circumstances to address
the varied mission of the department of
homeland security i'm extraordinarily
proud
of our volunteers can you confirm that
over the weekend you directed fema
uh to help receive shelter and transfer
on the company children from the
southwest border
yes indeed thank you and uh fema is the
same agency who is charged with his
first
nationwide disaster order and handling
the pandemic and distributing
vaccines uh it most certainly
is and it is extraordinarily capable in
addressing
uh the many challenges that we
throughout the department of homeland
security and throughout the nation
confront this is not the first time that
we have deployed
uh the the fantastic uh uh people of
fema
uh to address different challenges i
think i understand sir
thank you can you confirm that in order
to pay for the response to the surge at
the border it's highly likely
that you're going to need a supplemental
appropriations from congress
uh that is not certain by any means mr
ranking member and i certainly will
stay in close touch with you with
respect uh to the financial
impacts of the work that we are
performing not only in this mission set
but across the department
okay now uh a couple quick questions if
you agree with the facts we
that we've set out and i appreciate your
uh your candor and you said earlier in
your testimony that
the situation at the border is
undoubtedly difficult well given the
the tremendous rise in surge of
individuals coming to the border
wouldn't it be fair to call it a crisis
because that's what your agents are
calling it
um mr ranking member um first of all
if i may i didn't necessarily agree with
all the stat statistics
uh that you cited um mr ranking member
i'm not spending any time on the
language that we use uh i am spending
the time
on uh operational uh response
uh to the situation at the border okay i
just took that question
i know i'm almost done that's what i'm
focused on despite despite our
disagreements and despite the
language characterizations i want to
talk about solving problems and i just
want to get a commitment from you with
two things one is
that you're open to work with members of
congress regardless of whether they're
democrats
republican to reverse a disorder at the
border
i i will be a partner of members of
congress regardless of party okay and
lastly
mr chairman thank you for your
indulgence will you commit to
encouraging the president to accept
leader mccarthy's
well-intentioned invitation to discuss
the border crisis and i'd like to be
there too if i could
on how we could come together to fix it
uh mr ranking member i will defer to the
president
uh to uh how he uh believes he should
conduct um
uh the meetings uh that he hosts
thank you mr secretary you're back mr
chairman thank you very much
uh the chair now recognizes other
members for questioning
they may wish to ask the witness i
recognize members in
order of seniority alternating between
majority and minority
members are reminded to unmute
themselves
for wreck when recognized for
questioning and then mute themselves
once they have finished speaking
and to leave their cameras on so they
are visible
the chair now recognizes the young lady
from
texas miss jackson lee for five minutes
mr chairman thank you so very much for
your leadership to the secretary
it's good to see you again we've worked
together before my time is short
my questions i will try to be uh as
short as possible if your answers could
be likewise
i'm not raged about the shootings in
atlanta thank you for starting out we
offer our deepest sympathy
six of those individuals seem uh to be
asian out of eight
what is the department going to be doing
about uh
even though the investigation is not
proceeded uh what may be domestic
terrorism or hateful acts violent acts
against uh communities like asian
americans which have seen a surge
in hateful acts secretary very quickly
congresswoman it's nice to see you again
as well i won't comment on the um
the tragedy of yesterday because it is
under investigation
but we are intensely focused on the
greatest threat
that we face uh in the homeland from a
terrorism perspective as i mentioned at
the outset
and that is domestic violent extremism
uh uh
violence that is motivated by different
ideologies
including ideologies of hate uh against
particular social groups
i appreciate it i i hope that we will
focus on asian americans as we have done
on other groups and certainly we know
that african americans have been the
target of white supremacy and white
racism
let me move quickly to the border and
indicate to you mr secretary
that this administration has a border
policy
i congratulate you for it it is not a
policy of putting children in cages
which we had to suffer for year after
year on the trump administration
there are no children in cages so i
would simply ask
this i applaud the utilization of fema
and i applaud the utilization of a
policy can you succinctly say
what that policy is as it relates to the
border and your policy for
moving children who are now moving to
temporary sites like midland
uh and dallas uh to a process where they
can seek asylum and or
go to their custodial representative in
this country mr secretary
congresswoman the border is secure and
the border is not open
we are expelling under the cdc's public
health authority in light of the
pandemic single individuals who arrive
at the border
we are expelling families under that
same public health authority
uh limited only uh by the capacity
of mexico to receive them and we are not
expelling
children who arrive unaccompanied
without a parent or legal guardian
and we are caring for their custody and
their sheltering
in hhs's um responsibility
to place them with sponsors so that they
can proceed
uh with their immigration proceedings
and their claims for humanitarian relief
under the laws of this country in a safe
and orderly way
thank you mr secretary and as it relates
to covet 19 our state has always been a
hot spot texas
let me quickly uh cite legislation that
i have a coveted uh
uh delivery act of 2020 and 2021
just want to emphasize the value of fema
want to acknowledge tony robinson
region 6 administrator and the texas
department of emergency management
they've been working beautifully but i
want to emphasize that i think fema can
stand up
and do more as it relates to monitoring
shipments i think they can do more by
establishing an app
that would help working with hhs to uh
sort of monitor
the uh the vaccines as they're coming
forward
and so i just want to be able to work
with you on
ideas of how fema can be more effective
in the covet 19 fight would you work
with me on that
i most certainly will and i appreciate
the recommendation and the request
finally um we are all aware of the
horrible breach that came about
uh through solar winds and you mentioned
it in your uh
meeting excuse me in your presentation
so i'd really like you to
answer the question uh regarding the
importance
of having shared vulnerabilities meaning
that we have a system
and i of course have legislation but i
want to just focus on the concept
of making sure that we know the private
vulnerabilities and the public
vulnerabilities and that they are
they're shared under the umbrella of
system would you comment on that
we need to know the vulnerabilities so
that we can begin to address the
vulnerabilities
we can't have that kind of major breach
congresswoman uh thank you so much for
that question because it returns to
um a statement that i made at the very
outset and that is that the department
is a department of partnerships
and the public-private partnership is
especially important
in enhancing our nation's cyber security
security and infrastructure security
agency cisa
within the department of homeland
security is on point
uh for enhancing that partnership and
critically important to that partnership
is the sharing of information both by
the private sector
and the federal government by
understanding the vulnerabilities
by the attacks that individual
organizations suffer
by learning from them collectively we
will enhance
our nation's cyber security and that is
one of our critical
mission sets thank you so very much and
thank you for the work of the men and
women of the department
of homeland security look forward to
working with you mr chairman i yield
back
thank you very much chair recognizes the
gentleman from texas
for five minutes mr mccall
recent confirmation um
you know you and i i think have seen
this movie before
uh in 2014 when i was chairman of this
committee
and you were deputy secretary of dhs
obama called the surge of migrants
at the southern border a humanitarian
crisis
and he was right and today we're seeing
another surge at our southern border
we've both seen this movie before and we
know the plot
and we know the outcome as chief of
counterterrorism and national security
for the u.s attorney
in texas i learned that deterrence does
work
firsthand in fact mr secretary you were
a federal prosecutor in a border state
yourself
and i believe that words do matter i
know you mentioned that maybe the
language doesn't matter i think words do
matter
i think you sent exactly the wrong
message when you stated
quote we are not saying don't come we're
just saying
don't come now that is not a message of
deterrence
the trump administration in my judgment
did a masterful job in negotiating
the remaining mexico policy and the
asylum cooperative agreements with
central america
it was actually a foreign policy
achievement
and it worked migrants would have to
wait in mexico for their asylum trial
and the border was under control however
with the stroke of a pen
on inauguration day by president biden
these policies have been suddenly
reversed and cancelled cartels and
traffickers see that the green light is
on
at our southern border and the united
states is open for business
again again the message is come on in
just like that catch and release has
returned as a policy of this nation
and so mr secretary has the threat
migrants are given a date to appear in
court
and suddenly disappear the children are
the victims
and the cartels are celebrating this
victory
sir with all due respect this
administration has created this crisis
by rescinding these agreements and just
yesterday
you said quote we are on pace to
encounter
more individuals on the southwest border
than we have in the last
20 years that is staggering
and i appreciate your honesty i agree
with you it is going to be
uh the more most we've seen in 20 years
you may call that only a challenge but i
call that a crisis
so i must ask this question why in the
world
did this administration and president
biden
basically shred the trump
administration's
asylum agreements of mexico and central
america
this administration's actions have had a
direct cause and effect
on this humanitarian and border crisis
what was this administration and the
president thinking
congressman it's uh nice to see you
again and i'm very proud of the work
that we did together
when i was a deputy secretary and you
were the chairman
of this very esteemed uh committee
sometimes um the tools of deterrence
defy values and principles
for which we all stand
and uh one of those tools of deterrence
that the trump administration employed
was deplorable and absolutely
unacceptable
and if we want to speak of language then
let me speak of language
i'll i will share with you how i def uh
define a crisis
a crisis is when a nation is willing
to rip a nine-year-old child out of the
hands of his or her parent
and separate that family to deter future
migration
that to me is a humanitarian crisis
and what the president has committed to
and what i
am committed to and execute is to ensure
that we have an immigration system that
works
and that migration to our country is
safe orderly
and humane
congressman i was against separation
families as well but let me just say
this
um by rescinding these i think
you know i'm now the republican leader
of the foreign affairs committee so
i look at this also from a foreign
policy standpoint i think it was a
blunder to rescind these agreements
which have created this exact problem
and it put these children in jeopardy
and you're seeing the separation again
i again i i think you know what is
happening down there and i've been you
and i've been down there
so many times the kids children the
babies down there what how what a
humanitarian crisis it is
i don't think it's a coincidence that on
inaugural day the president rescinded
this foreign policy
and then all of a sudden within february
we have hundreds of thousands of people
coming in and a projected company by the
end of the year
congressman let me if i may um make two
points
uh one um uh in fact we have seen
migration surges before
2019 was extraordinary
2014 and before then and the bottom line
is and this is something about which we
all agree
the immigration system is broken and it
is in need of legislative
reform and the president presented a
bill
and there are bills pending before the
house and hopefully
this year and i am confident and
optimistic
that we will actually begin once and for
all
to fix a system that everyone agrees
with
the gentleman's time policy again
gentlemen's time has expired chair
recognizes this gentleman from rhode
island for five minutes
mr langevin thank you mr chairman i want
to thank you for convening this uh
this hearing uh mr secretary uh happy st
patrick's day
uh welcome before the committee and i
want to congratulate you on uh
taking over as uh the uh the secretary
of homeland security i should look
forward to working with you going
forward
um secretary marcus uh i i appreciate
showing my
my colleagues concern about border
security
though i have to say i i wish they had
raised them with the prior
administration instead of focus
focusing biopically on a wall but um
you know i'm concerned that we're losing
uh real sight of the
of the real threat that we face physical
borders aren't the only thing that
we have to be concerned with uh you know
we've seen in the last several months
some of the most pervasive cyber
incidents in our nation's history
what's more these incursions into our
uh endorsed cyberspace are at the behest
of our
greatest adversaries particularly china
so mr secretary i want to start off by
asking you how you view
cyber threats that we face as a nation
congressman i want to thank you for your
focus and your leadership
on this important mission set and i as i
mentioned before i want to thank the
committee
for its support of our department and
the infusion of much needed resources
to cisa cyber security and
infrastructure security agency
this is one of my uh four most urgent uh
priorities for the very reason you
articulate
uh the cyber threats that our country
faces
from nation-state actors as well as
individual actors
cannot be overstated the threat to
critical infrastructure
cannot be overstated and we've seen that
in a number of
exploitations in recent months and over
the past
uh several years we have incredibly
dedicated and talented individuals
who are focused on it uh the president
has
identified this as well as a critical
mission set
and anne newberger uh is an
extraordinary appointment as a deputy
national security advisor
focused on cyber security this too is an
all of government effort
thank you secretary and i'm glad you
touched on critical infrastructure
uh i'm a big proponent of the cyber
security and infrastructure security
agency's work
on risk analysis in fact i authored a
provision of last year's ndaa
codifying responsibilities of sector
risk management agencies
uh to support their that work now recent
events whether
uh uh the the cyber incidents tied to
solar winds or microsoft exchange server
or the uh the the frigid temperatures in
texas
uh have demonstrated how the failure
of a few important assets supporting
national critical infrastructure
uh natural critical functions can can
have cascading and
and often devastating effects so the
cyberspace salary commission on which i
serve as a
as a commissioner has suggested uh the
concept of
systemically important critical
infrastructure or sticky for lack of a
uh
of a better uh term but as a framework
for managing these risks
so secretary do you believe that sikhi
uh
based as it is on work uh the obama
administration did as part of executive
order
uh 13 636 is a useful framework
for managing risk particularly cyber
risks
uh congressman uh thank you i do and
that is very much the subject of our uh
discussion
and i really appreciate your focus on uh
critical infrastructure
it is a subject that i discussed uh with
the leadership
in the department of homeland security
on cyber security just a few days ago
because that is indeed a critical
critical
area uh upon which we all must focus and
i
really appreciate your work on the
commission thank you
secretary um also the salary commission
believes that
dhs uh is really the linchpin in helping
to mitigate risk before cascading
failures occur
uh do you agree uh with this is with
this assessment
and how do you how are you engaging with
your fellow cabinet secretaries
and the white house to better manage
risk uh to systemically important
entities
uh thank you congressman uh certainly uh
the department of homeland security and
cisa in particular
has a key role uh to play in the federal
government architecture
and as i mentioned earlier in response
to the congresswoman's question
the public-private partnership is key
and we are
of course uh on point for that i had a
um
a very important meeting uh with ms
neuberger uh just this past monday
morning
and we spoke about um uh everything that
we are doing
across uh the federal government in
executing the president's direction
that indeed we bring all resources uh to
bear because
each one of us has different assets
different capabilities
and different responsibilities this is
really
it's not just an all-of-government uh
effort i think as you have correctly
noted
in the past it's an all of nation
effort because here in cyber security we
say
uh that we are only as strong as our
weakest link
and um and so uh i share
your view uh that we must work uh all of
us together
in partnership to address the challenge
thank you mr dude i know that uh
my time's expired but uh you know i
believe that congress and particularly
this committee
are key partners with the department to
better protect sikhi and
i hope this committee ms chairman would
hold a hearing on this important topic
and
secretary i hope that you would uh
commit to working with us to uh
to address this uh systemic challenge
thank you
thank you very much tr recognizes
gentleman from louisiana
mr higgins for five minutes thank you mr
chairman mr secretary thank you for your
service to our country i have to say
though that
it's this meeting at this hearing for
many americans washington had been quite
nauseating thus far he carefully read
scripted statements i'm not sure you're
here to answer questions sir
i i suspect that you're here to present
a prepared narrative to the to the
inquiries of congress we
y you had stated that
we're not we're not saying don't come
we're saying don't come now
i can tell you my sources tell me
they're coming now
and they're coming through the year
you're looking but the cartels have two
million in the pipeline
we're absolutely looking at a 20-year
high for illegal crossings at our
southern border
my colleagues across the aisle not even
mentioning the cartels
america is watching this for god's sakes
we're going to blame
president trump you mentioned a 2019
surge we had a surge in 2019
because the cartels were paying
attention to the election cycle in 2018
when the democrats took the majority we
we had to use
every available legal power to
re-establish control in 2019
we did we had this thing down to a
manageable threat
what happened to whatever 2021 surge why
let me just put it out there what
happened between
between the control that we had and what
we have now they had the election
in november of 2020 and president biden
was
inaugurated on january the 20th
americans know they get it the the
cartels are paying attention
they've loaded up their pipeline we've
got two million illegal immigrants
headed our way
and i don't believe you have a plan to
deal with it and let me say regarding
fema
if there's not a crisis or a
humanitarian disaster
at the southern border then may i please
suggest we take our
female disaster response teams deployed
there and send them some there
somewhere where they're needed like my
district in southwest louisiana
where they're still hurricane victims
waiting on temporary housing
let me ask you a question and perhaps
you can answer mr secretary
do you do you agree that this the world
is currently experiencing a pandemic
and does does the world include nations
such as
mexico guatemala honduras el salvador
colombia venezuela panama cuba china
iran
is a world experience a pandemic
a congressman let me assure you of one
thing
before i answer your question which is
despite our strong different uh
differences of opinion
uh i look forward to working with you
towards share goals
that's very kind of you are we
experiencing a pandemic
of course the world is experiencing a
pandemic okay
we experience a pandemic and we're
experiencing
massive surges of illegals crossing our
southern border
you're you're the head of the department
of homeland security
are we testing individuals in the
facilities prior to their release into
the united states
and uh and i have a very direct answer
to thank you congressman
it is indeed our policy to test
individuals before releasing them and we
are testing them before or after that
process
we have a process set up uh to do so
uh and if you'd like i can explain that
process it has four parts
no uh what i what i'd like you to do is
just tell us
i have several questions are we testing
these
illegal immigrants that are being
released into our nation
are we testing them before or after the
process
you said they're being tested that you
have a plan in place
we most certainly we most certainly do
there are four
ways in which we accomplish uh the
testing
okay you're welcome to submit that in
writing i'm reclaiming my time
it to me i think the american people are
witnessing a question dodge the bottom
line is
uh illegal immigrants are being
processed at the border
and released into our nation that that i
have either not been tested
or tested posited for covert okay i
don't think i'm going to get a straight
answer from you
i have i have another simple question
do you believe that the policies
initiated by president biden since
his inauguration have impacted
the issues on the southern border and
increased illegal crossing
do you believe the cartels were paying
attention all
last year when then candid biden
was messaging and he was going to weaken
the law enforcement mission
uh provide some kind of a path towards
amnesty or citizenship
process when the illegal crossings in a
manner
that was that was more conducive to
their reception in the united states he
messaged that again and again and again
do you think the cartels heard that do
you think that maybe has something to do
with what we're dealing with right now
um congressman i i share a background
with ranking member catco
and congressman mccoy my goodness
gracious i'm not going to get it yes or
no
you know what i'm going to do i'm going
to submit my questions in writing
because you're not here to answer hard
questions sir you're here to repeat
narratives that's been prepared by staff
and attorneys
and i i don't appreciate you dodging
these questions mr chairman
i'm going to yield my time and submit my
questions officially in writing to the
secretary
and i'm going to expect them to be
answered and if they're not
we're going to make some noise i yield
gentlemen's time has expired
chair recognizes gentleman from new
jersey mr payne
thank you mr chairman um
you know i believe that
when a witness is before us he should be
given the opportunity to answer the
question
and not shout it over so in that vein i
will try to
do that uh
mr secretary we've uh we've seen a lot
of criminality
uh charged uh insurrectionists from um
the attack um on january 6
cite president trump's words as a reason
for participating
in the attack for example garrett miller
who was charged for
his role in attacking the u.s capitol
said that
i believe that i was following the
instructions of
president trump robert sanford who was
has been indicted for attacking capitol
police officer
our law enforcement uh people that
defend us
as was just stated by the previous
member our law enforcement
uh that he attacked
told the federal agents that he followed
the president's instructions
and uh gone to the capitol
for that day mr secretary is it fair to
say that
um that extremist groups see president
trump
as their leader of their movement
congressman the events of january 6
are the subject of criminal
investigations and prosecutions
so i would prefer uh out of respect for
the integrity of
that work uh not to answer specifically
with respect to the january 6th event
but what we all are seeing as i've
mentioned before
uh is a um a growing and persistent
uh threat and that is domestic violent
extremism
that is born of different ideologies
ideologies of hate ideologies of
anti-government
uh sentiment uh ideologies of uh
racially motivated
uh individuals uh and and that is what
we are very much
uh focused on here in the department of
homeland security
and uh their words do matter
but uh you you you can't say whether
um the impetus for january 6
was the insurrectioners following
president trump
it is it is not congressman something i
will comment on right now
in light of the investigations that are
underway in the evidentiary
impact uh of anything i say
ever since november 20th election we've
seen political leaders echo
former uh president trump's uh baseless
lies that
the election was stolen can you please
share with the committee uh
how repeating and amplifying these lies
inspires and encourages the same
extremists
who attacked the capital on january 6th
those uh those pronouncements
congressmen are not fact-based
uh they are actually in defiance of the
facts
um i think uh chris krebs who led the
cyber security and infrastructure
security agency during the prior
administration
uh who did a superb job uh and i have
seen the results of his great work uh
each day
um uh indicated uh that uh
based on evidence based on data
uh that uh the election uh uh
was uh conducted with uh integrity
and that the votes were not manipulated
so basically the loser of the election
was just
really just playing sour grapes and uh
trying to uh sway the american people to
believe that
there was something inherently wrong
with the election
is that correct uh congressman i i focus
on election security uh with our state
local tribal territorial
uh partners that is what uh i am i am
focused on
okay so the the president's um
president's echoes were baseless
thank you um mr chairman i yield back
the balance of my time
thank you very much chair recognized
gentlemen uh from mississippi mr guest
for five minutes
uh unmute yourself
thank you thank you mr chairman uh mr
secretary the american people are deeply
disturbed
with the ongoing crisis along our
southwest border
cbp numbers uh just in february so
uh encounters over 100 000 individuals
an
increase of over 170 percent
from the 36 687
encounters uh in february of 2020.
this issue is of growing concern to the
american public
and this is not a political issue we are
seeing calls by many members of the
democratic party
uh highlighting what we are seeing along
the southwest border
uh representative cuellar said earlier
we are weeks
maybe even days away from a crisis on
the southern border
an action is simply not an option our
country is currently
unprepared to handle a surge in
immigrants in the middle of a pandemic
we see democratic representative
vincente gonzalez say
i can assure you it won't be long before
we have tens of thousands of people
showing up on the border and it will be
catastrophic for our country
for our region and for our district
we heard just this week senator joe
manchin
senator manchin said whatever message
was sent
it was interpreted the wrong way it is a
crisis
oh it is a crisis
i know in statements that you recently
made you talk about how we are on pace
to encounter more
individuals on the southwest border than
we have
in the last 20 years
in february there was a letter signed by
over 50 members of congress
that letter was sent to the president a
copy of that letter was sent to you
in that letter the letter says we write
today to bring attention to the rising
immigration
crisis that is already beginning in our
southern border
a mere weeks into your administration
that letter goes on to say on your first
day as president
you signed multiple executive orders
dismantling the security of our border
we're sending policies from the trump
administration that were
working as intended to halt the flow of
illegal immigration
the biden administration direct is on
stopping the building of border
infrastructure
revoking policies ain't carrying out
interior enforcement
halting deportations for 100 days and
suspending
the migrant policy protections mpp
have all communicated that our borders
are open we know that the february
numbers of 100
000 individuals over 28 days
works out to an average encounter of
over 30
500 a day in 2019
at the surge of the crisis along our
southwest border
former dhs secretary johnson who was
secretary under the obama administration
he was questioned about this and just
two years ago he said
i know that a thousand being a thousand
cases a day
overwhelms the system i cannot begin to
imagine what 4 000 a day looks like
so we are truly in a crisis mr secretary
we are
approaching that 4 000 number that
secretary johnson described
as a crisis in the summer of 2019.
in the summer of 2019 both republicans
and democrats came together
they recognized that what we were seeing
the surge across our border
was an immigration crisis and it was a
humanitarian crisis
and it was a crisis that must be
addressed
we saw president trump put forth
policies
that almost immediately began to
overdress uh to address the overcrowding
that we saw
across our southwest border and i will
tell you it is time
that this administration do the same
thing in less than 60 days
they have completely destroyed what was
a successful
policies or roll back those successful
policies
by the trump administration mr secretary
i will close
my statement to you with a statement
made by former secretary of state
colin powell secretary of state colin
powell had what he referred to as
the pottery barn rule the pottery bond
rule said
you break it you own it mr chairman at
this time i yield back
gentlemen yields back chair recognizes
for five minutes mr correa
i mute yourself
mr correa can you hear me okay
yes thank you mr chairman for this
hearing and
mr secretary welcome um let me again
touch upon an issue my colleague brought
up which is the issue of covet 19
testing
at the border are you testing all the
refugees and for those refugees
that are not turned away for those
refugees that may come into the united
states
for further evaluation of their case if
they test
positive do you isolate them for the
requisite time to make sure that our
communities are safe
i know you wanted to elaborate on those
the solutions that you have so i want to
ask you to please elaborate
please be succinct specific and factual
thank you sir
uh thank you congressman uh so we have a
uh
four different ways in which we test
individuals
uh who come uh into the country
whom we do not expel um
we work with community-based
organizations and local officials
uh we release them uh into those
community
based organizations so that they are
tested
and quarantined there and we provide a
hundred percent reimbursement
through fema uh to the local uh entities
and the community-based organizations
provided the state authority does not
stand in the way
we work with states when those states
have the capacity
to um test and quarantine
uh we are working uh now uh with funds
appropriated by congress
to fund directly community-based
organizations and local facilities
to conduct the testing and quarantine
and when those three options are not
available
we have now retaining a vendor to
test individuals who are in cbp custody
and if in fact
they test positive uh we transport them
to ice facilities
for quarantine before release that is
our four-point
architecture and i appreciate the
opportunity to share it with this
committee
thank you sir mr secretary let me follow
up on the refugee issue
on deterrence following our federal laws
values principles
ending children in cages uh the ending
of children separation
i was watching spanish news a few days
ago i watched an
interview of a young lady no more than
14 years old
that had gone to the border she was
stating that she had gotten raped by
seven men before she got to the u.s
border
and we talk about deterrence and i can
only imagine
the drivers that push immigration north
the dangers at home the hunger so my
question to you is
when are we going to start what are the
long-term
solutions to this problem all of us
agree
this thing didn't happen one year two
years it's been going on for a
long time more than a decade two decades
what are the long-term solutions when
are we going to implement them thank you
sir
congressman uh thank you very much and
um i think
that uh jorge ramos put it very
powerfully uh andre vizion because i too
um i'll listen to spanish um language
television
and radio when he said that uh sometimes
hunger
is stronger than fear um
there are two long-term solutions
um both of which the president has
acted upon one of which is
immediately before us and that is to
finally
fix the immigration system in this
country the second
is to address the root causes in the
countries
from which these individuals are fleeing
uh and specifically the northern
triangle countries of guatemala honduras
and el salvador
we began to invest in those countries
and address the root causes and that
funding was discontinued during the
trump administration
and the president is committed to
restarting that critical
uh element of an overarching approach
uh to our border and the issues of
migration
that have challenged our nation for so
many years
thank you very much sir mr mr chair i
yield
gentleman years share recognizes
gentleman from north carolina for five
minutes mr bishop
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
secretary for your appearance
uh others have made reference to your
march one
statement what we are not saying
don't come we are saying don't come now
and i'd add to that in an abc
news interview that day you refused the
suggestion to say do not come period
president biden has said don't come
we're in the process of getting set up
and answering uh mr mccall you spoke
with the price of deterrence
mr secretary are you prepared to say
right now that it is wrong for people to
enter the united states illegally
of course i am so it's wrong to break
the law right
of course it is
or to incite migrants to do that am i
right sir
uh congressman uh of course it is wrong
uh to break the law and i dedicated uh
12 years of my career to prosecutors
most law breakers mr secretary
congressman perry elaboration here's the
question that i last asked you because
you answered the question
my question is so there can never be a
right time
to enter the company the country
illegally or to incite
migrants to do that isn't that correct
congressman if i may speak of the law
to which you refer because our country
has to explain the law sir i just asked
you uh
wrong mr bishop we allow the secretary
to answer your question
he's not answering my question mr
chairman he wants to go well well
i don't know i don't want you to debate
him uh
i'm not trying to debate him i just
wanted to answer my question
well if i if i may let me put the
question again
and then we'll see if i can get an
answer to my question
what i asked mr secretary is there
cannot ever
be a right time to enter the country
illegally or to incite migrants to do
that
would you agree a claim of asylum
an individual fleeing persecution by
reason of his or her membership
in a particular social group a claim of
asylum
is a claim that is recognized by
law in the united states of america and
an individual who makes a claim of
asylum
is not breaking the law by doing so
and as a law enforcement as a law
enforcement officer
i enforce the laws of accountability
as well as the humanitarian laws that
congress